what do you think about uh men who allow  women to beat on them  and smack them curse them out equal  rights equal lefts baby and a lot of the  conservatives will not agree with me on  this one but if she hits you hit back  stop it stop it yeah I'm not I used to I  used to think never hit a woman okay I  used to believe this really yeah and  then but it was because I where I grew  up if anyone hit a girl like a girl hit  a guy would be like hey you know and so  I'm like okay but I saw the punches that  these [ __ ] be throwing in I'm like if  you want to hit like a dude expect to  get hit like a dude because you don't  you don't go up to Dwayne The Rock  Johnson and punch him if you got punched  back no one would feel bad for you but  these girls will punch a dude and then  if he hits back everyone's mad it's like  she hit him first Plus